left-wing media is having a field day
with former president Trump's indictment
what a time to be alive my friend really
what a time to be alive we're all going
to be glued leaning forward to our
television sets on Tuesday of all of
this unravels as it looks like it is
before tonight presidents in this
country were Kings I mean I thought
maybe would never come I used to think
what does it matter if it came I didn't
know it would feel this good Michael
who's more pissed right now Melania or
Donald
uh definitively Donald
you know uh I am not usually here on a
Thursday night but
you know things happen deep breath
everybody the Jay and Donald J Trump now
stands for jail
certifiably Giddy and the ladies of the
view Greg's favorite throwing what they
call a celebration of the law watch
I called it did you
when I feel good
so it really is a celebration of the law
it's a celebration of the law and how it
applies to all of us
Donald Trump finally won a popular vote
yesterday the judge that that presided
over that case where the Trump family
was found guilty is the same judge
presiding over Donald Trump's 30 counts
okay but there seems to be a disconnect
with top Democrats the administration
that loves to bash Mega Republicans all
of a sudden has very little to say
Mr President do you think that the
charges against Trump are politically
motivated
what is your comment on former president
Donald Trump's indictment I am not going
to comment on an ongoing criminal case
as it relates to the former president
I'm surprised you didn't bust out a Venn
diagram now would be the perfect time
Greg uh you were you were on a roll
let's keep on that role well I mean I
don't honestly I don't blame them this
is basically this is kind of the the
flip side of the Roe v Wade decision
right the Roe v Wade you saw the kind of
the way the the left had said like oh my
God I mean you were I mean you predicted
it you said it was going to have quite
an impact on the on the Red Wave I think
this is going to have the reverse it
will have it will destroy any Blue Wave
and will probably create a red wave
because it energy this will energize uh
the voters the way the Roe v Wade
decision energized the left but I mean I
don't know uh the the media loves
political theater and incentivized
outrage so you know Nicole Wallace
didn't wasn't she involved in weapons of
mass destruction thousands of innocent
people murdered more than thousands like
hundreds of thousands in Iraq why is she
not in jail I mean I don't I mean maybe
she didn't break any laws but I'm just
assuming as far as horrible people go
she's got blood on her hands that Trump
doesn't Trump's always been a pacifist
right has he ever been pro-war no he was
originally for the Iraq War but then he
recanted I think I saw that interview
and he said yeah whatever I think it was
on Stern because he was like yeah I
guess it was after he had complained
about it so I I don't think he was
really Pro he just wanted he wanted to
dodge the question Jessica
judge yeah when he was president he
wasn't interested in war yeah and he
wanted to end the war uh in Afghanistan
but you know these people as you watch
them on television I mean these are
lawyers I mean Sunny whatever her name
is is a lawyer I mean that that is even
beneath her these people hate him so
much that they literally uh they have
this psychological disorder that they've
earned you know the trumped Arrangement
syndrome they created it and they earned
it and the whole idea that nobody is
above the law yeah Hunter Biden is above
the law Hillary Clinton is above the law
Joe Biden is above the law he's got
documents that were never supposed to be
taken out of a skiff he was a Senator
he's got these documents that forget
about you if you've got a president
that's one thing I mean at least they
are entitled there is a question as to
whether or not they can have the
documents but Joe Biden is stealing uh
classified documents when he was a
senator from Skiffs look the the the the
true truth is here that these people
just hate the left has been they've been
the haters from the beginning they were
the ones who said Donald Trump got
elected unfriend anyone who likes Donald
Trump don't talk to them anymore let's
break up the families let's not talk to
them anymore Joe Biden every day does a
dog whistle to the uh to the left with
those Mega Republicans they're horrible
people they create the division and then
they they feed on the division and the
hate and this is a product of it Jessica
to to Greg's point doesn't this make it
more likely that Donald Trump is the
nominee I mean there's a rally around
the flag effect that will happen here so
why are they so giddy nominee and
president again are two very different
things so but you can't be the president
without being the nominee 100 first of
all he was up 30 points in the Fox News
poll this week and there's been a lot
more chatter about whether DeSantis
should just wait frankly until 2028 that
this isn't his time he's a young guy you
know how another great term as the
governor of Florida and enter the race
When Donald Trump is out of it because
the base loves him and they want to
avenge what happened in 2020 by making
sure that he gets reelected again and I
think that he will be the nominee but to
the point about becoming president again
I I'm sure there are some examples of it
but I would say that certainly a
majority of people who voted in 2016 for
Donald Trump and then moved to Biden
those Independents and moderate
Republicans are not looking at this and
saying oh this makes me more excited to
vote for him right now you have a
candidate who's going to have a mug shot
right they wanted things
not just famous but Infamous I mean but
that's not inside of what they will
people didn't want like after living
through bikes I get it but like no one
wanted like Bonnie and Clyde in the
white house right they didn't want like
John Dillinger in the White House great
it'd be cool
stop it stop it to this whole thing
about that we're the ones that tore
families apart I am old enough to
remember what Donald Trump's rallies and
he just had one last weekend where like
the chance of lock her up the talks of
beating up members of the press that he
would pay
um for their legal fees no no just don't
ask if Biden talk about taking him out
back and like out teach him
six-year-old man when he did that or 77
year old man making a joke like that
having uh
it's okay for him listen as he passed
his prime Jessica just he I mean
that's a really unfair there are
obviously obviously people who do don't
want to know people who feel different
differently than them politically but I
know plenty of people would say to me
cry harder live and like you're a big
libtard and you love Hillary Clinton
we've all got stories come on yeah
for these folks though who are dancing
and excited now it's kind of like the
Washington thing you have to be careful
what you ask for what you celebrate and
the the Traditions that you break or
that you set because every time they
change the rules with like how you can
confirm judges or the filibuster or
anything else on the hill you got to
warn the minority party you know like
when they come back they're going to
want Vengeance so you have to remember
now that you've said that the state
prosecutors can do these kinds of things
you have to know that in some places
there may be Republican prosecutors who
will look at Democratic Targets in a
different way and say the door is open
now that's a great Point Traditions that
you break or precedence that you break I
mean it was the Democrats who lowered
the bar for justices which opened up the
opportunity for Trump to include three
new justices so when you break it the
other side
about it it's a shot all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else